so i've been wanting to make a video
like this for a while
because over the years i've been
collecting
a lot of weird and bizarre opening traps
that have not gone in games on stream
and i figured i'd compile a bunch of
them into
a single video and i hope this brings
some
enlightenment some entertainment a lot
of these are going to be really weird
bizarre traps
that are extremely rare some of them are
really dubious that you shouldn't really
try at home
but then others are a bit more practical
that uh you can get
in in real games uh play against typical
openings
and and maybe score a few victories
further down the road
so before we get into the traps
i do have to think today's sponsor is
audible.com
if you haven't heard of them they have a
massive collection
of audiobooks and podcasts and really
anything you can listen to
you can find on audible so if you want
to get a free audiobook
of your choice you can use a link in the
description
audible.com i am rosen or you can text i
am rosen
to 500 500. last time i did one of these
i
gave a book recommendation the art of
learning
today i'll give another recommendation
it's called all the wrong moves
and it's by sasha chapin this is a
really really
fascinating story really great listen
sasha talks about his experience as a
chess amateur
and developing kind of an addiction
to the game traveling around the world
competing in events
he visited st louis got coaching from
ben feingold
he has so many interesting stories to
tell
and i think a lot of my viewers can
potentially relate
to his experience so if you want to get
this audiobook
or any other audiobook for free on
audible
again you can use the link in the
description audible.com
i am rosen or text i am rosen to 500 500
and let's get back into some opening
traps
okay so this first one i
discovered about eight months ago i was
playing against a grandmaster
in a bullet game uh this was off stream
i was black
i'll actually flip the board because
i'll share from my perspective
and then we'll flip back to the white
perspective
i encountered the trompowsky opening
and i decided to play what i thought was
a really really solid
setup basically resembling a queen's
gambit
declined and my opponent developed
naturally
so far nothing too weird i played b6
very normal
to play bishop b7 and c5
and here my opponent played kind of the
first
peculiar move of the game queen a4
and at first i thought okay maybe this
is a positional idea
opponent wants to maybe play bishop a6
and trade off
lights for bishops we can bite light
squares i just continued here played
bishop b7
and already white is scoring
82 percent after 95
and actually after 95 um
black is most likely to fall into the
trap
and blunder with taking on e5 so this is
where we're gonna flip back the board
and try and figure out why knight takes
e5
is actually just a losing move and we'll
play it on the board
knight takes e5 pawn takes e5
and knight d7 so in this position
i'm going to give this as a puzzle this
is white to move
find the absolutely crushing move which
just wins
a lot of material on the spot and here
is where we see
the true reason behind queen a4
it was not to influence the queen side
but mainly to swing over to the king's
side
after queen h4 black is um in deep deep
trouble
there's a mate threat on each seven and
there's also
the threat of bishop takes e7 which
would then consequently fork the queen
and the
rook and at this point black is already
dead
um i did fight on for uh for a few more
moves i think i played g6
but after my opponent took on e7 i'm uh
i'm just gonna be down a rook in the end
of things
and i went on to lose a game so this is
a really cool one
and this is one which i'm thankful i
discovered because
i won't fall for it again as black and
it's it's really nice kind of using the
whole board geometry
uh developing the queen this way with
intention
to swing the queen all the way over
and this is why queens can be so tricky
even early in the game is uh they can
really make use of the whole board
and effectively target the weaknesses in
the opponen's position
so just to show there have been
almost 300 players that have fallen into
this
this exact position on the chess white
winning 97 percent of the games from
here
so let's move on to the next one next
one is gonna be
a a much weirder one and this is one i'm
going to say that you should not
try at home because it's basically pure
hope chess
and even if the opponent falls into it
it's not really good
but i'm just showing this for more
entertainment purposes
so this one i'm calling the dumb queen
e7 trap
and it emerges after normal king's pawn
on move two black will play queen e7
and normally this is uh just a really
bad positional move
usually you should not develop your
queen this early
and especially to e7 where you block in
the bishop
but there is um kind of a deeper
tactical idea
and i i became aware of this a few years
ago
that i forgot about it and then in
trying to think of traps for this video
i i remembered it and figured i would
include it
so the potential trap white can fall
into is when white tries to play
a so-called fried liver attack with
bishop c4
and knight g5 so if we imagine bishop c4
knight f6 knight g5 this is already
not a great move for white and after
black's next move
white is going to be in a bit of a
predicament
um surprisingly enough black can play h6
and provoke white to take on f7
and incredibly it's not good for white
to take on f7
with either the bishop or the knight
due to some tactical reasons if bishop
takes f7
this is a simpler line black plays king
d8
and all of a sudden the knight is
attacked knight is also tied down to
defending the bishop black is just
winning a piece here
even though we lost casting rights we
can turn on the engine
and engine will say black is
oh it's already yeah minus three so
almost no compensation for white
um where it gets murkier is if
light takes with a knight on f7
and this actually turns into a kind of a
chaotic position
but the point is black can play rook h7
and now this knight is a bit stuck and
black's next move is going to be pawn d5
and very likely the knight will be lost
now this position if we look on the
chess white still scores well here
after the move pawn d4 and if we turn on
the engine
engine will say um like it's close to
equal
like black has to play somewhat
precisely
actually the engine's a bit confused
here on on what to do i guess we can
play d6
or maybe even takes on d4 maintaining
the idea of d5
but the positions here get really murky
and it's a type of thing i probably
wouldn't recommend studying too deeply
um just given that you shouldn't be
playing this opening trap too often
but it's a cool idea especially um
because
after knight f6 knight g5 has been
played
over 400 times and
it's it's kind of a surprise when h6
comes
and white is not better according to the
engine
so let's move on to the next one so this
next one is going to feature
a really cool tactical idea emerging
from kind of a bizarre line in the
kerokan
so the move star e4 c6 d4 d5
mainline kerocon knight c3 trail on e4
and now knight f6 i know if you ever
watch uh gotham chess
play blitz this is one of his favorite
lines in the carol khan
for black and the main line here is to
take on
f6 but the secondary move is
knight to g3 and after knight g3
black can pressure white right away
and we should actually look from black's
respective
because it will be black trapping white
in just a few more moves
black can be ultra aggressive play pawn
h5
threatening to play pawn h4 and further
kick around the knight
so if we imagine white still tries to
play actively goes for bishop g5
which has been played a number of times
before black plays h4
y trades on f6 but instead of taking
back
the bishop black takes the knight now
white saves the bishop
this brings us to a really unusual
position where it is equal material
but black has a pawn on g3 the h file is
half open
and it is black to move and i will say
from this position there is a really
really
just breathtaking tactical idea
that i do encourage viewers to find so
if you want to take your time
feel free to pause the video and find
the
amazing sequence for black in this
position
so i will say there's actually two
winning moves
but both of them use the same idea and
it's just a matter
of deciding which move order that you
want to play
but we are going to see a queen
sacrifice
i think the easiest move to start with
is
to take on h2 where we
hit the rook um if white doesn't want to
lose a rook on each one white has to
take back
and now we're in an interesting
situation because we would love to take
back
and then try and promote but if we take
back too soon
white will just take back and it's a
fair trade
so this is where we play an in-between
move
or what the germans call suicide
and we start with queen a5 check
hitting the king but also hitting the
bishop this is just as important
because after white blocks a check
imagine pawn c3
we sack our queen for the bishop oh no
my queen
and after white takes back we now take
the rook
and this pawn is guaranteed to promote
and the queen is guaranteed to be reborn
if knight f3 oh yes my queen
or if queen h5 preventing h1 queen
we just take the knight and promote and
whatever happens
black will be up material so this is a
really cool one
especially really before move 10
to force a line where we sack our queen
to guarantee promotion
i'll share one more kind of cool
variation here
if after queen a5 queen d2
the best move for black is to use a very
nice deflection tactic
and take on f2 exploiting the fact that
king is tied down to the queen
so if takes we win the queen and
um of course the queen can't take
because it's pinned to the king
and if king e2 we can then trade queens
and then
take and promote and be absolutely
crushing
in this position so this is a nice one
um not one that you'll see every day
most players won't go into this line as
white
but if we look on the leeches database
we can see this has happened actually a
few times
where looks like a few of the players
did go into this rook h2 rook h2 queen
a5
c3 and yeah all seven players who
reach this position knew to take on e5
so good job to these people
and maybe there can be a few more games
added to the list
after this video is posted so let's move
on
to number four this next one i have a
story
to go along with the trap is a few years
ago
i played in over the board blitz
tournament against the grand master
and before the game they kind of
stumbled
into the playing hall they almost showed
up late
which usually you shouldn't do for a
blitz tournament
and uh they were carrying a glass of
wine
didn't appear to be so sober and
opening also was a bit weird they played
the alakan
which is a legitimate opening
but um after a few move like c6 was a
bit
offbeat and i played c4 and
my opponent played knight to b4 and
i could tell my opponent was not so
focused looking around and i thought
they were just
in a very bad frame of mind
especially to be playing a serious chess
game so without too much thought
i went ahead and played a3
in this position and i should note i was
rated
over 2200 at the time so i was a master
level player
um but i still walked into what
what we can call an elementary trap and
as it turns out in this position a3
is a blunder and it walks straight into
the trap
and now it's black to move how can we
actually make use of the knight
on b4 well i played a3 i was expecting
the knight to go back to a6
but black has a way to win material in
this position
if you don't see the move immediately
feel free to pause the video
and find the way black can win material
here
and if you're guessing queen takes d4
you would be absolutely right
queen d4 is actually a really aesthetic
in-between move kind of a counter-attack
um
hitting the knight but also temporarily
sacking the queen
if white were to take it black strikes
back with a triple fork
and okay if king d2 knight takes d4
black has won a pawn in the process and
has a very fine position so queen takes
d4
uh just wins a clean pawn um
i think my opponent was kind of acting
during the game
like the glass of wine was maybe there
to make me underestimate my opponent
but i had to learn the hard way
and it was another one of these times
where
once i i fall into the trap once i won't
fall into it again
and we can see on the chest this is
actually a somewhat common trap over a
thousand
people almost 1500 people have
been victims of this from the white side
and it does turn out if we go back uh
just a couple moves
the best move is to delay c4 and play
bishop e2 complete development
and then save c4 for later after c4
knight b4 white's already under pressure
here
because we can't play a3 queen diggs g4
is already a threat
the engine will say it's uh it's
approximately equal here
and it's actually easy for white to go
wrong in some of these lines
um after bishop e3 black scores quite
well after bishop
f5 keeping initiative and um
and generating some activity so this is
actually not a bad line for black
and especially in faster time controls
if you do play c6 c4 is one of the most
popular moves from light
and if we look at the stats in this
position the most played move
on leech s is pawn a3 so white would be
quite likely to fall into the trap from
this position
so there's a few lessons to take away
from this one
of course you should always be
tactically alert in the opening
especially when your opponent is playing
weird moves like this you should always
ask yourself what potential tactics does
opponents
want to do and you should never judge
your opponent
based on how sober they may or may not
be
so let's move on and this next one is uh
is a cool one this is going to be a
calculation exercise
and it's based off a game i played
a few years ago against grand master
steven zerk
and while i mean the show did not
actually happen in the game
it was more of just an interesting kind
of sideline
that i thought of during the game so i
was white we went into
the sideline of a french defense and
then
entered what uh i don't even know
i guess lee chess calls this the the
winner
variation alekhine marathi gambit
um this resembles kind of a rubinstein
variation of a french
and we reached a position where i was
feeling good
had some active knights a bit more space
my point responded with knight gf6
and in this position i had a decision to
make
whether to take the knights maybe defend
my knights
uh play a move like knight g5 so i was
taking time here
and the first move i really wanted to
play was knight g5
um now in a blitz game i would probably
play this
relatively quickly because it has a cool
threat of knight takes e6
and if we play it out knight g5 imagine
black is negligent
plays h6 we can go in and
very nicely trap the queen
now this is not the line i went for
and i want to go back to this position
because before i play knight g5 i have
to of course calculate what
black will do and the calculation i made
was
was castling as one of the most natural
moves
and then i was thinking can i get away
with taking
on e6 because after pawn takes e6
knight takes e6 the queen is not quite
trapped but after queen e8
i would have knight takes c7 forking the
rook
and the queen and if you calculate just
this far
it looks like there's some perhaps
promise for whites
a lot of initiative even the white sack
tonight
i've won a few pawns on the process
probably winning
winning some more material with the rook
in the corner
so for the people watching i want you to
try and visualize this line
so one more time knight g5 castling
takes e6 takes e6 takes e6
queen e8 knight takes c7 try and really
visualize the position and remind me
later
and find the way in which black would
continue
after knight c7 i'll remove the arrows
just in case that makes things cleaner
and if you need more time feel free to
pause the video
but i will say the the reason why this
line doesn't work
is because after knight c7 black has
checkmate in one
and i remember uh when i realized it
during the game i
i've probably physically smiled
physically smiled mentally smiled
because it's not the type of
idea that you see every day or visualize
every day
but i will play this out on the board in
case
some people are struggling if i did go
into this line
and took on c7 this would be really
really tragic for white
and the maiden one is not to move the
queen
but to unleash the queen play bishop b4
double check and mate
because i have no way to move the king
no way to block
you cannot block a double check in chess
and this would be game over so
thankfully in the game i didn't go for
that
and uh instead i took on f6
it was still a fight the game ended in a
draw
but then um when i was preparing for
this video i checked the lead chess
database
and knight g5 is the most played move
10 people castled and then one sad
soul took on e6
took on c7 and got mated just like this
so there's been only one victim
on the chest in this trap maybe there
will be more
after this video but it's another reason
why you should be
very tactically alert in the opening and
really try and think ahead
before you you run into trouble in lines
like this
so let's move on to chapter number six
this next one i only discovered within
the last week
i was browsing the chess subreddit
and i couldn't find the original post um
that i came across but there is a
screenshot
of a trap against a smith mora which i
had never seen before which i thought
was really cool
so i figured i would show it in in the
series
um out of all the traps i feel like this
one is maybe the most likely that people
have actually seen before but for those
who haven't
it's a trap where you can play as black
and wind material in less than 10 moves
so this is mainline smith mora black is
going to
accept the gambit and then employ a
setup with e6
and bishop to b4 and i hadn't seen this
before
because bishop b4 is just not a line
i've
i've looked into i usually play knight
c6 which is a bit more
classical of a move but after bishop to
b4
if we follow the most common moves from
white
most common is bishop c4
black can play queen c7 here and then
over 2800 people play queenie 2
which turns out to be a blunder and i
remember the reddit post it was actually
talking about
one way to find opening traps is to use
a lechas database
and look for variations where there's a
very high scoring
percentage for one player so we can see
after queenie
ii black is scoring um 57
which especially early in the opening
that's kind of
an anomaly and for good reason
after queen to e2 black has a really
nice tactical shot
and again if you want to pause the video
and find the way
black can win material in this position
feel free to do so
okay so if you still don't see it at the
very least
you should be aware of what we're
looking to target in this position
the bishop and the knight are under a
good deal of pressure from black's
bishop and queen
and the key idea here is just to apply
a bit more pressure so white will
crumble
on the queen side and the way to do that
is to thrust
the b-pawn forward to b5 hitting the
bishop
but also exploiting the pins in the
position
we can say that there's two pins here
the knight is
pinned to the king this is an absolute
pin
but there's also a relative pin this
bishop in some sense is pinned
to the knight so if the bishop were to
take on
b5 black will take on c3 and after it
takes
takes black is hitting the king in the
rook
and this is already a decisive advantage
for black so after b5
the computer will say black has uh
close to winning advantage um i guess uh
the best move is to take
if the bishop moves anywhere else we're
still going to take with the same
tactical
ideas so if we dig in a bit closer here
takes takes takes um the best try for
white
is to i guess sadly give away the rook
and castle that's interesting the the
computer
says minus 1.4
after knight d2 but then it immediately
says um
minus three maybe it's still a bit
confused working through some of the
complications
um but this is a winning advantage for
black you should be careful with the
queen
um as long as you don't blunder or get
your queen trapped
and complete development you should be
having very good odds to
to win the game so this is a nice and
simple one
i might even try it myself whenever i
encounter the smith mora
and the one last thing i'll say if you
do go into this line
if we go back to when black plays bishop
to b4
this is a slightly offbeat move and
if you're going to play this line you
have to be prepared for queen d4
which is a bit unpleasant hitting the
bishop hitting the queen
and then if i were to study this opening
seriously
i would either prepare the line takes
takes knight f6 e5 knight c6
which is uh maybe slightly better for
white but still playable
there's also kind of a funny move bishop
f8
which is a computer's top choice so um
one thing when you go for opening traps
you should also be prepared for
when the opponent doesn't fall into the
trap and still have some idea
of what to do and know how to avoid
getting in trouble
okay let's move on to chapter number
seven
which is one that i actually discovered
from a friend who sent me a dm
on instagram and my friend discovered
this trap
from another friend named dewberry
so we're going to call this a dewberry
trap and after a little bit of research
i discovered that magnus carlsen
could have been a victim to this trap he
actually walked straight into it
but then his opponent didn't play the
the crushing move
so the trap starts as a sicilian
accelerated dragon very popular
variation
mike's going to play the main line kind
of going for a yugoslav setup
and in this position if we look at the
stats on the chess
most common move by far is knight f6 but
the fourth most popular move
is actually a very big blunder
and it has been played almost 30
thousand times online
including by magnus carlsen who we see
oh we don't see this is dr
nitristine2554
oh no so this was just clickbait
oh i i was doing a bit of prep earlier
and just assumed carlson walked into
this
but it's one of these carlson imposter
accounts never mind
um but maybe maybe carlson will still
have some potential to fall into this
someday
uh let's let's just remove that
sorry for the the click bait or fake
news
anyway that doesn't take away from the
the beauty of the next move
and after a6 um white has a lot of
different moves here
and i'm going to hide this for now
because the best move
from white is actually the ninth most
popular move
played on the chess and uh
it's somewhat computer inspired but if
you do want to find it
feel free to pause the video and try and
find the really nice
uh tactical aggressive move white can
play
in this position and for this one i will
again reveal the opening book and we'll
count down
so it's not queen d2 not bishop c4
not bishop e2 not f3 not knight takes c6
not any pawn moves but it's knight to d5
and this is actually this is another
case where we can
kind of sense that this is uh the trappy
move
based on the score for white out of the
468 games it featured 95
white scores 86 and the reason why this
move is so powerful
is because it immediately targets this
very weak
b6 square and it has the threat
of taking on c6
and then playing bishop to b6 so if
black
tries to develop normally we can take
and whatever pawn black takes back with
let's say
d-pawn actually if b-pawn takes we trap
the queen so this would be nice
and if d-pawn takes we still play bishop
e6
queen d7 knight c7 and we're winning
some nice material so it turns out after
knight d5
black's in really big trouble because
there's not too many ways to remedy
the issue of this this really weak b6
square
in black's territory another attempt
would be knight takes d4
but this just runs into bishop takes d4
and black
is still having a massive headache here
uh we're still threatening to
do nasty things on the queen side and if
takes
takes this is just complete domination
for whites
if we ask stockfish it's already giving
a decisive advantage
um we can have some fun kind of
exploring some of these lines
knight f6 knight b6 rook b8
e5 white just continues to throw punches
and laugh at the fact that black's
pieces
are pretty much in shambles
so i think the best move again if we ask
the engine
after knight d5 uh best move is bishop
to e5
which is not a move you usually want to
play early on in the dragon
because now the bishop becomes a target
and
the move i i think i would prefer here
is f4 just targeting the bishop
forced him to move back to c7
and this is again just nice domination
white might not be winning material
immediately
but after a move like queen f3 white is
uh
is really just dictating play
controlling the center
finishing development and having a very
very pleasant position moving forward
so this is a nice one um to capitalize
on
a somewhat offbeat move and special
thanks again
to dewberry for uh being responsible
of making me aware of this trap
okay moving on to the very last trap
i have in store and i'm not sure if
we're saving the best for last
but we're definitely saving the weirdest
for last
and for this last one i have to give
full credit to
international master operawison
for i think being the only player ever
to unleash this trap and he's actually
had it
on four separate occasions on the chess
we're going to see a seven move game
where he sacks his queen
for mate and it's gonna be a very very
bizarre sequence
so i'm gonna go ahead and hide the
notation and we're gonna see how
the play strangely unfolds starts with
knight c3
uh does this opening have a name the
vangeet opening
a bit offbeat but not too weird just yet
black plays g6 now
he plays d3 i'm getting a little bit
weirder
bishop g7 and now queen d2 okay this is
starting to look very strange
um but it is played with some purpose
black plays e6 and i will say i've
i did not talk to opera wisdom directly
but i have a feeling that he
created this trap because he knew
some opponents default to this kind of
weird setup
kind of the start of a hippo opening and
when black employs a setup
it does create some opportunity to
exploit
the weak dark spurs and we're going to
see how
white does that after knight to e4
knight e7 here's where white setup
is going to begin to make some sense
and we're going to see the reason white
played queen d2
is to throw the queen all the way across
the board
to h6 and uh
already this is actually a kind of a
work of art
um we're gonna look in the database
there have been four games with bishop
takes h6
oh no his queen they've all been played
by opera weson
and from this position white has
checkmate in two
after knight f6 king f8 bishop h6
checkmate a very cool mating idea
he's actually played this uh looks like
seven times
and as far as i can tell all the games
have uh
have been his so the more frequent move
here is castling
and if we ask stockfish what's going on
it does give
an a pretty healthy advantage to black
but this doesn't stop opera wesson from
playing it
and all the games here has been against
the same opponent
um he had one other game i do want to
show after queen h4
d5 knight f6 king h8 was played
and uh tragically black got mated
in eight moves so looks like
this opponent costia cornienko
has been victimized a couple of times in
in this opening
i should also note um if we
view the game on leeches this was ultra
bullets
i think all of the games opera wasn't
played this were in ultra bullets
so um probably not the type of trap to
use
in slower chests but sometimes when the
time control is quicker
you can get away with doing really crazy
stuff
like throwing your queen to h6 on move
five
so that wraps things up for
the traps in this video i do have a few
questions for the audience actually
um let me know in the comments what your
favorite trap was
if you've seen any of these traps before
because i did try to
to have some more fresh content that uh
has not been covered in my streams or
elsewhere
and let me know what you'd like to see
in future videos if you want me
to make another opening traps video like
this
or if there's specific openings that you
want me to cover i'd love to hear some
feedback
and also let me know if you have any
questions and
i will leave a link to the study in the
video description
if you want to explore these lines and
analyze a bit further
with stockfish or the opening book
and with that i will see you guys in the
next video